I'm very happy to introduce professor
Robert Hoover to you who is Nobel Prize
laureate from 1988 in chemistry no
professor who but you are a very busy
person you teach at several universities
around the world you have two companies
and you regularly come to Linda to the
meeting what you expected here well
first to see a wonderful place of my
home country Bavaria Linda is beautiful
and to meet the international students
so I'd like to discuss with them and
they come to me and all my patients and
to I like to interact with them that
means students can also help Nobel Prize
laureates to get new ideas in a sense
ear spy posing the right questions and
asking things that I didn't think about
so that's certainly a moment for me also
to learn and for them to learn from me
and and hear about my experience now you
actually worked in the field of
photosynthesis and you develop to x-ray
crystallography to look at protein
special proteins how has your discovery
changed the world well it has changed
the world in that sense that we now
understand the biology and the players
in biology which are proteins and other
biomolecules at the atomic level we see
them and there is no understanding
without seeing an object and this is
what x-ray crystallography provides all
of this was a development from the 60s
on then Nobel price is the most
important scientific price in the world
how much influence does your word have
today well it certainly has influence
with the students
I mean this is nice to see in one of the
reasons why I came to talk to them they
listened does it have influence in the
field of of politics and particularly in
the field of those people were with
those people that finance our reserve
politicians have other constraints
budget constraints and I noticed that
the attraction of this Linda meeting for
politicians have increased substantially
in the last five years or so so
ministers are coming addressing us
testing the students so that's another
very good aspect that the Linda meeting
yes sounds very successful to me thanks
a lot for the talk over to was a
pleasure